you guys wanted to make a short video to
speak up for a friend of mine who's been
silenced and doxed and blackmailed and
threatened by two youtubers who are much
bigger than him and I feel like he
doesn't have the platform to defend
himself both in terms of his audience
reach and in terms of the fact that
anytime he posts a video it's
immediately copy right striked and so I
want to speak up on his behalf and I'm
gonna try to keep this short so I don't
bore anybody a longer video detailing
the full story will eventually be made
but I don't have time to do that right
now and given that this is a fast
evolving situation I thought it was
important to get this video out to large
youtubers one with 400,000 subscribers
and one with 700,000 subscribers each
played a role in daxing blackmailing and
threatening a much smaller youtuber
named Trin black a few days ago one of
them released his full name on a webpage
that was designed to try to make sure
that he never got a job that was
preceded by several days even months of
threats I was part of some of those
exchanges as an intermediary and I tried
to prevent this Ducks from happening and
tried to explain that this is not the
action that should be taken but let's be
clear about how we got here we got here
because tech lead a youtuber did not
like one of Trin blacks criticism videos
and he copyright striped that video and
eventually two videos of trend blacks
Channel eventually he would release
those claims but not before trend black
was forced to give up his full name this
information was then passed off to
another disgruntled youtuber named Matt
Tran who trend black had also made a
critical video about Matt Tran was very
angry and in December they both told him
that unless he removed his videos they
would be Daxing him I asked Matt Tran if
he thought that this was blackmail he
initially said it wasn't but ultimately
agreed with me that that's exactly what
it was it's gonna come and yet he made a
choice his source was to keep the video
up well and I might work with my fault
my choice was to make I do not think it
was blackmail I don't yes black now at
all I'm looking
at the definition right now I want to be
clear here well it says blackmail is the
art of act of coercion using the threat
of revealing or publicizing either
substantially true or false information
about a person or people unless certain
demands are met
I mean it's textbook like it is
blackmail I want to be clear now whether
you think it was justified blackmail is
another thing but it is blackmail I mean
it's not like yeah eventually it was
decided that they would not DOX him but
a few months later Matt Tran
independently changed his mind and
decided to Doc's trend and let's be
clear where did this name come from it
came from YouTube's garbage copyright
system which allows anyone to get
private information about you with
literally no evidence that what you
posted is theirs you can go and submit
an abusive takedown request of any video
on this platform and you will receive
that creator's full name address and
phone number
what insane world do we live in where
that's acceptable it's not it's not
acceptable and that's exactly what
happened and that's how tech lead got
his information and ultimately that's
how Matt Tran got his information to
eventually docks him I asked Matt Tran
if this is indeed where he got the
information from let me ask you did did
a tech lead get or did you get to the
name from tech lead yeah yeah to add
insult to injury
now Trin black is put in a position
where his full name has been Doc's due
to YouTube's absurd copyright system due
to tech leads absurd abuse of the system
but now now after posting a video about
it that video was then falsely taken
down by tech lead the video that trim
black posted had zero footage of tech
lead in it and guess what tech lead
claimed that video so no one can see it
he's damage controlling to prevent the
information that trim black was Doc's
using the same system that he used to
initially find the information that
ultimately resulted in the daxing of
trend black this is absolutely
unacceptable and I wanted to speak up to
tell people that
is enough now the last thing I want to
say here is addressed to all of you
watching who are not Team YouTube please
do not go harass anybody involved this
situation is hard enough as it is
without people going and doing stupid
stuff they shouldn't the point of this
video is to highlight a broken copyright
system that allows way too much
information to be shown yes it was a
terrible horrible thing that trend got
doxxed but let's not go i for an i
instead this is a job for youtube to
solve it was their system that was used
to dock strenght black and they should
ultimately be the ones to decide what
kind of penalty punishment or anything
like that is ultimately done and
honestly the whole system needs to be
reformed because it is way too easy to
get way too much private information
about someone that can be used to docks
them or worse I'm begging you guys
please do not make things worse by
turning this into a harassment fest
that is not the point of this video it's
to shed light on a very serious problem
that's all for now I don't want to make
this video longer than it has to be
thanks for watching I'll see you next
time